we have just gotten wind of the best
political news in many months no I'm not
talking about Republicans taking over
the House of Representatives no I'm not
talking about Republican candidates
surging in the 2024 polls I am talking
about In-N-Out Burger coming to the
great state of Tennessee
's we have some very exciting news today
a great American company
an iconic brand In and Out Burger has
decided to place their first corporate
Hub in the eastern United States right
here in Tennessee In and Out Burger is a
great family business that's been
operating for decades in this country
with a value system and a way of serving
their customers that lines up just right
here in Tennessee and it means a lot of
opportunity and a lot of jobs for a lot
of tennesseans we are excited about the
opportunity that in and out is going to
bring to Tennessee plus we're going to
get to have double double fries and
shakes right here in the great state of
Tennessee welcome in and out burger
you're going to love it here the news is
so great not only because I will soon be
able to eat double doubles whenever I
want it's consequential because in and
out is about as California a company as
ever there was you think in and out you
think California
but In and Out Burger has a deeper
identity than that In-N-Out Burger is a
Christian company it's got Bible verses
on all the rappers and we all know that
it's getting harder and harder for
Christians to do business in
aggressively anti-christian States
frankly forget for a moment that in and
out is a Christian company in and out
burger is a company and it's getting
harder and harder for any company of any
kind to operate in left-wing states that
are hostile to business altogether that
is why we here at the daily wire all
fled new Cellini's hellscape for the
free air of Tennessee two and a half
years ago that's why countless other
companies have left over the past few
years and that is why I promise you in
and out will not be the last to leave
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at Norm's music who says FBI
stands for forget Biden's
irresponsibility
you know I am a sucker for a good play
on words you know I'm also a sucker for
a good night's sleep which is why I
strongly recommend Helix mattress right
now head on over to helixsleep.com
Knowles with everything going on in the
world right now you could use a good
night's sleep that is why you got to
check out Helix mattress Helix is a
premium mattress brand that provides
tailored mattresses based on your unique
sleep preferences the Helix lineup
includes 14 unique mattresses including
a collection of luxury models a mattress
for Big and Tall sleepers and even a
mattress made just for kids I have had
my Helix mattress for about three years
now I absolutely love it are you nervous
about buying a mattress online you do
not have to be Helix has a sleep quiz
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why would you buy a mattress
that's made for somebody else go to
helixsleep.com Knowles take their
two-minute sleep quiz find the perfect
mattress for your body and sleep type
your mattress will come right to your
door for free plus Helix has a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they will even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you will Helix has over 12 000 five-star
reviews they're financing options and
flexible payment plans make it so that a
great night's sleep is never far away
for a limited time Helix is offering up
to 350 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners this is
their best offer yet so head on over to
helixsleep.com Knowles with Helix better
sleep starts now I left California
a few years ago
I have very little business that I still
conduct in California the very teeny
little bit of business I do is two or
three times a year I fly out to
California because I host a show called
the book club at prageru and we film
them in blocks so we'll do three or four
or five books even in one long couple
days of filming and I was supposed to
fly out this evening to get to
California
speaking of not only California but also
getting in and out I was supposed to fly
out this evening and then I wake up this
morning and sweet little Elisa turns to
me on the bed she goes Mac say yeah
because my mom's at the airport in New
York and says the flights are delayed
and I said well good thing I'm not
flying out of New York I don't think
that I'm going to find your mother
they're not surprised that flights out
of the New York airport so she says no
Mac it's not just New York
it's all the flights so we think it's
all the flights
to pull up my phone
and the top trend on social media is the
FAA
because for the first time since 9 11
all domestic flights in the United
States have been grounded
so I would just like to before we get to
anything else happening today just
congratulate Pete bootage on a job well
done he you know Pete bootage just keeps
impressing us day after day it was
really good that he returned from his I
think three years of paternity leave he
he was able to stop chest feeding long
enough to go in and do his cabinet level
job and uh he's been back in the job for
a little while now and all of the
airplanes go down for the first time in
22 years that's really great really good
job keep it up Pete keep it up it's not
just Pete keep it up Biden
Administration this is really really
great stuff we've got we've got the
latest news on it now the FAA says they
are working to restore the notice to air
missions system and Performing final
validation checks and reloading the
system now operations across the
national airspace system are affected uh
Pete bootage Edge is trying to run some
damage control here he said I've been in
touch with the FAA this morning about an
outage affecting key system for
providing safety information to Pilots
ifaa is working to resolve this issue
swiftly and safely so that air traffic
can resume normal operations and will
continue to provide updates that's
really great and so why is this
happening there are a couple theories as
to why this is happening
there are three actually
the first is this is potentially some
sort of attack could be is it just a
computer glitch that just accidentally
happened or is there some targeted
attack that is going on right now at the
FDA ffaa could be that is it because of
wokeness John cardillo just posted this
Theory to social media he pointed out
now hold on it disappeared from there we
go he says below are the Department of
Transportation and FAA Focus points in
the 2023 budget
the kind of words that you see Pop Up
are racial Equity inclusion
income inequality environmental justice
and climate change we know that Pete
Buddha judge when he took over the FAA
or rather the Department of
Transportation entirely Pete Buda judge
said that one of his key focuses was
going to be on those racist bridges that
in the New York area there were Bridges
and Roads that are racist somehow he's
going to root out the racism from
Transportation okay uh if you're going
to focus on that you might not be
putting sufficient focus on keeping the
airplanes up in the air and people
traveling to where they need to go it
could be wokeness that's the second
theory of what it was the third theory
is just that this Administration is
incompetent
and that bleeds over a little bit into
the first two possibilities
maybe the the Biden Administration is so
incompetent that they let some attack
get through maybe the Biden
Administration is so incompetent that
they put all of their attention on
wokeness and weren't able to keep the
mechanics of the government running
maybe the Biden Administration is just
so incompetent they pushed the wrong
button we don't know exactly what it is
apparently the system has been restored
at least to some degree now so one hopes
that everyone's airplanes get off the
ground and that I can make it to to Los
Angeles so I can talk about Dusty old
books on prageru which would be a lot of
fun but it's a metaphor I think that
this
mornings government malfunction is a
metaphor for the the broader dysfunction
within the political system because
if you if you have ever flown on an
airplane at all you know
just one flight delay can affect
the whole system just one delay because
when there's one delay on one airplane
that means that it's going to arrive at
its destination a little bit later which
means that the flight that's supposed to
take off from the gate after that or
from that very same airplane is going to
take off a little bit later which means
people are going to miss their
connections which means people are going
to have to be rebooked on different
airplanes which means that there might
not be enough seats on that airplane so
some people are going to have their
flights canceled they're going to have
to rebook the next day which means
you're going to see Ripple effects the
next day and that's just one flight
being delayed from one location what
happens when you shut the whole system
down it's really hard to put the system
all up again these stupid minor little
errors can have huge Ripple effects
you've certainly saw that with covid
you can't just shut the system down and
then expect the whole thing to turn back
on again just like that that's not how
it happens when the government imposed
those lockdowns during covid it has led
it continues to lead to Mayhem
throughout the economy throughout the
political order
throughout the legal system even the
rights that were taken away from us that
is is why I always go back to this line
from the first season of the crown that
the head of the royal household tells to
Queen Elizabeth who says oh what's it's
not a big deal when there are these
little mess-ups these little fudging of
the rules and he says no it's in the
little things that the rot begins it's
in it's in all of these little tiny
things where sometimes even we
conservatives we say oh who cares it's
not a big deal oh yeah there we go some
stupid error or some some ridiculous
woke agenda item oh it's just a little
thing who cares who cares about the
bathrooms who cares about this who cares
about that
government Society is made up of lots
and lots and lots of those little things
and when all those air is creeping they
can have outsized influence you're
saying this right now
speaking of flyover country you're
seeing this right now in Idaho you're
seeing parents pushing back against all
these little tiny things because for so
long conservatives just took it I said
okay these crazy Libs they they want
their weird sexual agenda in the Public
Square they want their parades they okay
whatever who cares all right they want
to redefine marriage okay who cares all
right they want to bring the drag queens
into the schools okay all right okay
they want to let boys go into the little
girls room in the elementary school okay
I guess who cares who cares well if we
don't care about any of these things
then I guess we just don't care about
our politics and we've surrendered our
self-government fortunately parents are
standing up where spineless Republican
politicians have have failed to stand up
you're seeing this in the Caldwell
School District right now
there was an agenda item before the
school board it was called policy I mean
it still is called policy
3281 and it's a policy that would let
the boys go into the girls bathroom
among other aspects of the trans agenda
and what you saw occur at this school
board meeting was you saw the people
broadly pushing back against this and
one state senator in particular but a
representative of the political order
coming in pushing back as well against a
corrupt school board and I'll tell you
they looked good doing it when you want
to look good you got to check out mizen
and Maine right now head on over to
mizzeninmaine.com use code Knowles
Missin and Maine are the inventors of
the performance fabric dress shirt is
there anything worse than wearing an
uncomfortable kind of dress shirt that
gets all wrinkly and terrible missing in
Maine doesn't think there is anything
worse at all that's why they made the
most lightweight breathable and moisture
wicking dress shirt that you can buy
their high performance dress shirts are
warm in Winter and cool in summer think
of their clothing as your secret weapon
for any occasion I am confident that if
you give Mason and Main a try you will
never go back to Conventional men's
clothing again
dress shirts are absolutely phenomenal
and by the way it's not just the dress
shirts I love in particular they're polo
shirts oh my gosh they not only because
the fabric is so great and as an Italian
American I perspire a little bit but
they look so smart man are they they are
really really clean elegant shirts
that's why Miss intermitted has over
thirty thousand five star reviews online
look your best this season with missing
in Maine right now if you go to visit in
maine.com use promo code Knowles you'll
receive 35 off any regular priced order
of 125 or more
m-i-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com promo code
Knowles
state senator Chris trachel stood up to
this school board with
a broad representation of his
constituents behind him standing up to
the people who want to trans the kids
you claim you want people to follow the
rules but you break the rules left and
right last month you allowed two people
we will resize for 15 minutes
[Music]
I'm sorry we have asked you absolutely
know the protocol you're not following
protocol yourself
Madam chair move to adjourn okay I have
a motion to adjourn do I have a second
I love this woman who's trying to run
the school board meeting she goes the
moment she gets pushed back she goes
okay I'm going to adjourn the meeting
I I don't want to have to answer these
questions I don't want to have to
explain the policy so I move to adjourn
do I have a second
because you need you need someone to
Second your motion and then nobody in
the room wants to do it do I have a
second and you hear the the herons in
the crowd they say no you don't have a
second answer the question stop
transiting our kids
and and this woman looks to her fellow
school board members do I have do I have
a second
and then there's this all this dead
signs finally someone second so much she
goes okay second of the motion
we're journeying see ya bye-bye
absolute embarrassment so it's it's
important to see these things happen at
the local level it's important to shine
a light on these movements at the local
level because it is it is in those small
things where the rot can begin and it's
in those small tiny little things where
a a return to sanity can begin as well
where recovery can begin where a
restoration of our country can begin as
well the other reason I bring up this
clip is because conservatives are fond
of saying
politics is Downstream of culture
and if that means that conservatives
should take over Hollywood again
great I agree
and if that means conservatives should
produce great works of art that shape
one's mind and soul good and if that
means that conservatives should
I don't know should conservatives start
exercising some control over education
that's cultural to a degree but now
we're starting to get a little bit
political isn't it because the
government has a say over education
and if if a state senator wants to show
up to a local school board and with a
group of parents is that cultural or is
that political I have long been
skeptical of this phrase politics is
Downstream of culture
because
not because it isn't true in the sense
that we need to make movies but because
I think it lets Republican politicians
off the hook
I think it is a kind of libertarian cope
to say the government is always bad the
government can never do anything right
so we just need people outside of the
government to do everything for us
it's a way to say okay we're going to
surrender the entire political order but
we live in a republic we live in
self-government
so in self-government in all states but
especially in self-government
the distinction between the culture and
the politics is pretty blurry because
it's we the people are supposed to be
doing both of those things what was that
meeting last night what was that episode
was that culture or was that politics I
bet that a ton of those people probably
probably every single person in that
room saw the daily wire Loudoun County
story where we exposed what happens when
boys are allowed to go into the girls
room and it can result in rapes and all
sorts of cover-ups and just terrible
disorder I bet you most people in that
room saw Matt's movie what is a woman
which exposed a lot of the transgender I
bet they've been following a lot of
cultural outlets on this question sure
but there's a state senator there and
the people would not have been nearly as
effective if the state senator had not
come in as well
and it's the people fighting against a
political body and what they're trying
to do is get a law rate a school rule to
be shot down to change the way that the
school is going to conduct business
isn't that politics or culture
there's both it's both and conservatives
I think we've gotten the message this
was the thesis of my my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
which is still available for order and
selling like hotcakes really appreciate
that there we go a little light on the
Bell today but that's all right we'll
pick it up it's early in the morning all
the flights are grounded everything's
chaos we'll probably get the Bell a
little bit quicker next time I mention
specialists
guys come on what are we doing where's
the iron okay we got a
we'll try a little bit later in the show
regardless my point is that I think
conservatives have gotten the message in
recent years that there's nothing wrong
with wielding the government within just
limits for good ends there's nothing
wrong with that we have to do that
otherwise we're surrendering not just
our politics but our whole culture we're
surrendering the whole country to the
libs and that's not going to turn out
very well because very very quickly the
the political predations of the libs are
going to go from hiking our taxes a
little bit and kind of putting some
annoying regulations on us to transiting
our kids it's going to go it's happening
very very quickly it's happening before
our very eyes you want to talk about
culture and politics coming together
destroyment to get to yesterday but
certainly want to get to it today
diamond
of diamond and silk Fame has suddenly
died unexpectedly died very very sad uh
if if you can
spare a prayer for Diamond I think that
would be a wonderful thing to do I I did
not know Diamond particularly well I did
her show at least once I think maybe
twice we'd they've been on my show we
have we interacted a fair bit and they
were they as a Duo silk is still alive
but diamond and silk as a Duo were so
funny and so perceptive I I was going
back through some of the best of the
other day and just thinking man what a
great
what a great something this was I didn't
I could is it an act is it a political
campaign is it whatever it was it was
really really great
hey y'all okay so I'm sitting up looking
at my TV and I'm disturbed by what I see
okay okay now you got everybody all
upset because now people are talking
about deporting illegal immigrants back
to their country okay when they came
here illegally and see now you have the
president done Wade in it in on it okay
and he said it's not who we are as
Americans okay and I say no Mr President
it's not who you are as an American We
As Americans want our border secure
that's why we can feel safe in our
country We As Americans want our jobs
back here in our country where we can
Thrive again we as Americans baby want
to know that we matter first and we go
Outsiders so charity starts at home okay
we as Americans want our government to
realize that it's easier and cheaper for
you to deport instead of support okay
all right now I know that we're the land
of the freedom but it doesn't mean for
people to come over here in our country
illegally that's why I get free food
free houses
immigration you are is wrong it is wrong
in this country when we as Americans if
we go to somebody house Uninvited yeah
and we go right up in their house they
call that breaking an interesting
what a great bit what a great what a
great
performance that is but what is it is it
just a show is it just entertainment
it's certainly entertaining
is it education it is educational
diamond in particular with silk as the
cheering Squad in in the the Act was
explaining the illegal immigration issue
as well as I've heard it explained
and knocking down the Democrat talking
points on immigration in a way that was
funny but was educational is it
philosophy actually there was a
Fair level of political philosophy in
that conversation the the analogies that
she's drawing
she says you know when I go into
somebody's home if if my friend and I go
into somebody's home that's called
breaking and airing why is it different
when a foreigner comes into our country
illegally what I know it seems basic but
we're in an age of such chaos and
confusion that that's an Illuminating
analogy to make what is it is it is it
political activism is it campaigning is
it politics diamond and silk would go
all around with Donald Trump
so what is it is it culture is it
politics
I don't think you can distinguish the
two between the two
I agree with Ronald Reagan someone
knocked Ronald Reagan back in the 80s
for being an actor so do you really
think that an actor can be the president
of the United States and he said how
could the president not be an actor
so much of the job is theatrical so much
of the job is cultural when you think of
the great achievements of Ronald Reagan
probably the biggest achievement was a
cultural one which is that he made
Americans feel good about themselves
again
now that was the point of mourning In
America which is his most famous Ed it's
morning in America he accomplished a lot
of great concrete things he got the
economy going again he defeated the
Soviet Union I'm not downplaying any of
that but the longer lasting deeper
accomplishment that Ronald Reagan had
probably was a cultural one
and so
it should not be in either or okay we
should yeah we want people who have a
good show business Knack in politics and
and we want people in our culture who
are unafraid to wield the political
order but the other reason that I was so
sad to see Diamond die is that with
Diamond's death and with the end of the
diamond and silk Act
I think it symbolized it symbolizes the
end of an era an era that we know has
passed away
but but we're not really conscious of
that fact
until until A Moment Like This
diamond and silk are as significant to
the Trump era
as any other symbol I can think of when
I think back to those wild crazy days of
2015 2016 that today feel like just
yesterday until you begin to remember oh
yeah Donald Trump coming down the
escalator and oh yeah Hillary everyone
thought Hillary Clinton was going to be
the president it was just a guaranteed
thing and then oh yeah we had these
women diamond and silk and they became
so popular they ended up
getting a a show and they ended up
campaigning with the president and oh
yeah that feeling of When Donald Trump
won and the Maga hat and oh yeah do you
remember this feeling of Hope and
and that was a long time ago
that was seven years eight years ago
when the Trump campaign began eight
years ago it's almost a decade ago
and and the thing about eras is
you don't feel them passing away you
only you only realize that they're gone
when you think back on them but it's not
as though you're in in a moment most of
the time you just think okay all right
now today June 5th 2021 this is the day
that it that one era passed away and
we're into a new one no it's just
it happens subtly and then you look back
and you say oh my gosh yeah that era is
over
and so then we have to ask ourselves
what is the fight now what are people
going to remember now I also don't mean
it to say that Donald Trump is done and
he's totally cooked and there's no way
he's going to win the presidency again
but he and his campaign certainly has to
recognize this and we all also also have
to recognize this
whatever Trump 2015 was whatever that
moment that moment is over
and in fact the reason that Trump was
able to win I think in 2016 is because
he recognized that the moment that all
the other GOP guys were campaigning in
she was really like a 2010-2012 tea
party ish moment
or in the case of Jeb it was a 2005 kind
of bush era moment
that that was all done and so Trump says
things that would have been completely
unacceptable during the early tea party
era and during the bush era
we need to
we need trade tariffs we need we need to
build up a wall
the illegal immigrants are murderers and
rapists I'm going to lock Hillary up in
jail all these sorts of things virtually
every Canada on that stage
was uncomfortable with something that
Donald Trump said because
he was campaigning on the new thing on
the present while they were they were
campaigning in the past so the question
for us is
what is the issue now what is going to
Define 2023 and 2024
the issue now I have argued for
some months is is more meta political
than political by which I mean it's not
just that we're fighting one issue Or
Another We're not just fighting taxes
we're not just fighting
regulation we're not just fighting
abortion even we got the Dobbs decision
Roe v Wade is dead
there's still a lot of work to do in the
pro-life movement to protect babies but
even that that's not the
the most important issue in most
people's perception even if it is the
most important issue ultimately because
it's an issue of human life
what I think people are focused on and
will increasingly be focused on
is meta Politics the politics of
politics how decisions are made how
power is wielded in our country knowing
that our government is not run like the
bill up on Capitol Hill like our
Founders and framers intended
I think this is probably why the House
GOP
which for all their faults at the very
least they usually have a decent enough
sense of what issues people care about
because what they're often focused on is
just getting themselves reelected the
House GOP has just voted to defund the
IRS specifically they voted unanimously
to repeal the Democrats Army of 87 000
IRS agents the very first Act of the new
Congress says Kevin McCarthy because
government should work for you not
against you promises made Promises Kept
now the establishment GOP can justify a
vote like this on its usual rounds which
is that we just want to cut taxes the
only thing that Republicans ever seem to
agree on is that we just want to cut
taxes but this is about more than that
it's about cutting the agents it's about
shrinking the agency it's about stopping
Joe Biden's massive
increase to one of the executive
agencies that has been used
since at least the Obama Administration
to persecute conservatives this is
really not about taxes
I'm all for a tax cut please cut my
taxes that sounds great but it's really
not about that what this is really about
is how power is wielded in the country
who has that power
who can wield it and who is going to
wield it against whom because right now
it's being wielded by the libs against
us in increasingly
arbitrary ways or capricious ways not
not arbitrary in the sense that we know
who's doing it and who they're doing it
against but but in ways that are
unmoored from any kind of principle or
rule that applies to everybody
politics
is being set at levels much higher than
the US Congress I think this is why
people have an increased focus on the
world economic forum
I think this is why a lot of the
political debate in recent years has not
been about the left versus the right or
the Democrats versus the Republicans a
lot of the political debate in the last
six or seven years has been about the
nationalists or the Patriots versus the
globalists that's a that's a big shift
and you are seeing globalist political
power represented in its clearest
expression just this coming week at
Davos at the world economic Forum most
people don't know what the world
economic forum is the world economic
forum is this
non-profit organization that was founded
in 1971 by Klaus Schwab who looks and
sounds like a James Bond villain and
acts like one too but it's not a
governmental body exactly
and it's not a private organization
exactly
the world economic forum
gets Government funding from governments
all over the world the world economic
Forum hosts tons of heads of state 53 I
think this year 52 heads of state
are participating in the annual meeting
of the world economic forum
52 heads of state that's a massive
number and nearly 300 government
ministers are going to be participating
in the world economic forum and what is
the purpose of the Forum the purpose of
the Forum is to bring together
the public sphere and the private sphere
all over the world
exactly what we've been talking about in
this show to bring together the politics
and the culture
and to pull it all together
so that when we decide in Davos that
climate change is a really big problem
you know after we fly in on our I think
at the current moment it's something
like 1500 private jets it might be more
like 2500 private jets fly into Davos
and we're really worried
about how you you Hoy polloi are using
gas stoves that's very bad for the
environment I was reading an article
about it on my private jet flying into
my Swiss mountain town in Davos it's
very bad and so what we need to do is
not only pressure the governments to
take away your rights and traditions and
way of life we're going to pressure the
companies too and we're going to
pressure the non-profit organizations
the ngos that have a lot of power around
the world and we're going to force them
all working together
conspiring you might say to pursue our
agenda the Davos agenda
the agenda of the Davos man that that
phrase has come into Vogue in recent
years the Davos man
is the sort of person who doesn't feel
any particular local or national
Allegiance the Davos man who all he ever
does is works on his laptop he could
work anywhere in the world he feels far
greater camaraderie a far closer kinship
to the same sort of people who just Jet
Set all over the world and they they
mock things like patriotism they mock
things like tradition like our ordinary
way of life
like having a family like like being
rooted in a place they they mock that
that's not for them
that's happening right now and so how
does this work in practice a lot of that
sounds kind of abstract well the way it
works in practice is right now the Davos
agenda is to make the rest of the world
look like China to make the West which
has a tradition of Freedom a tradition
rooted in Christianity a a tradition of
the
most impressive civilization ever to
Grace the Earth
yeah that's all that's no good all that
freedom all those rights that you say
that you have that's really that's
that's hurting mother Gaia that's that's
uh provoking the sun monster to destroy
us all that's not giving these people
enough political power in Davos no no
you're a tradition of of political
Freedom where you have your own
representative bodies and you make your
own laws for your own that's not good
you know increasingly globalized world
and so what what the wef has suggested
is that the model for the future is the
China Mountain what's the China model
you don't have rights you don't have
freedom you don't have your tradition
you have constant surveillance and the
people at the tippy tippy top tell you
exactly what you do all of the time that
is in fact a bigger political issue
than whatever the marginal tax rate is
in the United States and conservatives
are waking up to that fact and you were
seeing it reflected in our activism you
know in 2022
we launched Jeremy's razors as a joke
but just because it was a joke did not
mean it was not real it was an important
joke now
just nine months and 15 premium products
later we've amassed the largest social
media following of any brand in the
category and taken over 10 million
dollars away from so-called Men's
Grooming companies that despise
masculinity that was just the beginning
this year we've got even more great
products and woke scorching Endeavors in
store so skip the resolutions and Join
the Revolution together we will upend
the woke economy and finally give
conservatives a return to what they
believe are you ready
to really make a change this year pick
up Jeremy's razors Hair Skin beard and
body care products today by going to
dailywire.com
how do you think I get this quaff this
is Jeremy's shampoo go to dailywire.com
Knowles
the situation
the metapolitical situation of these
davos-like people these Geniuses these
these self-appointed benevolent Bettors
who are going to take all our rights and
sovereignty and traditions away and
they're going to tell us exactly how to
live
there there are so Brazen in in their
approach to things and their vision is
so so hideous
that you you are seeing even the pope
speak out against it
and I I say this
with some surprise because or or at
least recognizing the surprise that many
of you might feel when you hear this
because Pope Francis has a reputation of
being
a little bit more on the liberal side
a little bit confusing in some of his
statements a little bit soft maybe on
the Chinese government a little bit more
favorable toward these liberal
globalists around the world
that is at least the public perception
and I think that the public has reason
to understand those things but as I have
tried to point out time and time again
Pope Francis is not just the Communist
caricature that you read about in the
newspapers people try to portray Pope
Francis as pro-lgbt agenda they forget
that he said when he was Cardinal of
Buenos Aires that gay marriage quote
unquote is not merely a political
campaign but rather quote a machination
of the Father of Lies who seeks to
deceive and confuse the children of God
and when he was asked by specifically by
the German Bishops but by a lot of the
libs within the Catholic Church to
permit blessing Ceremonies for gay
marriage and that sort of thing Pope
Francis said that the Vatican cannot
bless sin
and so he's been very clear he sounds
extremely right-wing and based on an
issue such as that on abortion some
people might suspect because
Pope Francis sounds kind of liberal
sometimes
that in our
secular world if you don't understand
the history and the inertia and the
authority of the church
you might expect Pope Francis to be
pro-abortion he's not he said that if
you go and get an abortion it's like
hiring a Hitman okay you can't be any
clearer than that and even on this issue
of the big Libs The the globalist type
people who want to bring us zip off
Industrial Revolution as the world
economic Forum calls it that this this
complete upending of society where
artificial intelligence and computers
are basically going to run the show and
we're going to seed all of our political
rights and traditions to to the
computers basically to technology under
the control of an increasingly
globalized Elite Pope Francis says hey
watch out there are strict limits here
that you cannot pass a really important
statement he just made to the
Renaissance conference in Rome the
Renaissance with the AI capitalized in
it is a
a Catholic uh
campaign focused on the ethics of
artificial intelligence and Pope Francis
said we are all aware of how artificial
intelligence is increasingly present in
every aspect of daily life both personal
and social it affects the way we
understand the world and ourselves it's
really important too because
you know we're all afraid of being
turned into cyborgs but in many ways we
already are cyborgs when you are walking
around
how often are you not looking at your
phone when you are just walking in your
day-to-day life or at the office or in
school or wherever how often do you not
have your phone on you I try to not have
my phone on me and people get angry at
me they say I just texted you why didn't
you text me because I never text anybody
back well I I just called you where I
saw it under my phone on me what do you
mean well this if your phone is always
on you and you're always plugged into it
then you are in a way of sort of a
cyborg and it affects the way that you
view even who you are but Francis goes
on he says innovation in this field
means that these tools are increasingly
decisive in human activity and even
compelling in human decision making now
let's put a pause there he's saying it's
not the technology does not merely
facilitate the decisions that you want
to make the technology increasingly
pushes you toward the decisions that it
wants you to make that's what social
media algorithms are that's what when
you go shopping on Amazon that's what
Amazon is doing it's pushing you toward
purchasing certain products the the tick
tock and the Instagram and the who knows
what of it all
are pushing you toward consuming certain
images which is pushing you toward
cultivating certain desires which is
pushing you even further toward the ends
that it has in store for you
and it's not just the computer that has
these ends in store it's the people
running the computers and so
so rather than just seat our lives away
to the people who make the algorithms
and run the computers that motivate our
decisions but for instances
I encourage you
ethicists on AI to continue in your
Endeavor I am pleased to know that you
also wish to involve the other great
world religions and men and women of
Good Will so that Al Gore ethics ethical
reflection on the use of algorithms will
be increasingly present not only in
public debate but also in the
development of Technical Solutions put a
pause there this is a really strange
statement to come from the pope where he
says I'm glad you're involving the other
great world religions hold on the claim
of the Catholic church is that the
Catholic church is the the divinely
instituted Church of Earth the spiritual
Israel the bride of Christ on earth and
the pope is the Vicar of Christ and so
this relativistic language of all the
other great world religions oh you know
we're all accessing the truth man and
you know we're all I grab the truth and
I I think that God is like a a tree a
big tree trunk and I think that God is
like a fire hose and I think that God is
like a big wall and actually it turns
out when we all see how how we're really
thinking of these things someday
we were all touching an elephant you
know and one person was touching the leg
and one person was touching the trunk
and one person was touching the side and
so we were all all the religions are
kind of getting at the same thing man
you know we're just no one has a
monopoly on the truth that's not a
Catholic idea okay the Catholic idea is
actually yes the church does have a
monopoly unreligious truth because God
has a monopoly on religious truth and
Christ on Earth instituted this this
church and and gave a special role to
the apostles and specifically to the
successor to Saint Peter and to the
successor of Saint Peter so Catholics in
particular are going to look at the
statement from Pope Francis and say wait
what's going on here come on and maybe
it's because Pope Francis is a big labor
or something but I I would prefer to
interpret this in a more charitable way
which is I think Pope Francis
is rightly observing that
the the immediate battle that we have to
fight right now against this
Leviathan that stands before us this
battle that we have to fight right now
against the increasingly technologically
powerful
atheist globalist secular Elite
means that we are going that the battle
lines are not going to be
the Catholics versus the Presbyterians
that's not the that's not maybe that's a
battle for another day I don't know arm
up you Presbyterian someday someday
we'll hash out that battle but that's
not what's going on right now the battle
is not even between the Christians and
the Muslims we've had those battles
called the Crusades battles not between
the Christians and the Jews the battle
is not that the battle right now
is between it's it's on a much lower
grounding actually it's it's sad that it
has to be on this really basic level but
it's between people who recognize that
there is a metaphysical reality that God
exists that the soul exists the world
economic Forum says the soul doesn't
exist Yuval Harari who is the one of the
philosophers of the world economic Forum
he says the soul this is fake news the
resurrection of Jesus Christ this is
fake news It's Not Human Rights it's
fake news
and so the battle here is yeah if you
want to if you want to get anything done
we we need supporters here and so the
battle is between people who recognize
God exists humans are made in the image
of God
and we're not just we're not just stuff
and matter to be dragged Along by a
computer and an algorithm that's how I'm
choosing to interpret that and I think I
think if that is the correct
interpretation it certainly if if that
is what Pope Francis had in mind or
whether it isn't what Pope Francis had
in mind it certainly is
true of the situation nevertheless he
goes on he says indeed every person must
be able to enjoy a human and supportive
development without anyone being
excluded we must therefore be vigilant
and work to ensure that the
discriminatory use of these instruments
does not take root at the expense of the
most fragile and excluded let us always
remember that the way we treat the last
and least of our brothers and sisters
speaks of the value we place upon human
life we can take the example of Asylum
Seekers we can take the example of all
of the marginalized people who are
fragile and excluded let us remember
that uh that it is not acceptable that
the decision about someone's life and
future be entrusted to an algorithm and
this is really important
you are
you are seeing here
that the the real Line in the Sand is
humans must remain the stewards of
creation
we can't just delegate that away like
the Congress delegated away so many of
its powers to the alphabet agencies in
the executive branch we cannot just
delegate away our stewardship of the
creation to a computer
we cannot establish the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human life this is one of the strong
arguments against in vitro fertilization
or increasingly you're hearing really
messed up stories there's one I wanted
to get to today we don't have time to do
it about the actress Anna Kendrick who
was lamenting her breakup she said I'm
I've had this boyfriend and we made
embryos together and then we broke up
okay well you made it means you had
children together
you you've got Souls on ice over there
and you say I no longer care about my
children let them freeze forever or let
them be destroyed let them die or
whatever
one of the arguments against things like
in vitro fertilization yeah there are
many arguments but one of which is it
establishes the domination of Technology
over the origin and Destiny of human
life
it disrespects our
our own humanity and we as as people who
were made in the image and likeness of
God that is a huge threat there is
always a political battle between
between policies that will degrade human
beings or policies that will recognize
the Dignity of human beings what's
happening right now because of the the
means and opportunity afforded by
technological advancement and
globalization
we are at the precipice of a major
battle and it's not a battle over tax
cuts it's a battle over who controls us
it's a battle over what controls us it's
it's a battle over
what will human beings even be going
into the future now we have got a
wonderful movie trailer
that I I'm assured by my producers
is provides ample fodder for our
reflection on our decadent culture
because it is woke Wednesday but if you
want to give me your brilliant thoughts
on this trailer and you want to hear my
cultural musings as the most fresh hip
cool youthful vibrant uh cultural
commentator out there you've got to
become a member of daily wire so head on
over dailywire.com Knowles
use code nulls at checkout get two
months free
on all annual plans we will see you at
the member block
[Music]
[Music]